The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: All right.
Let's dive right into education.
And, you know, this is the
other side of the innovation
equation, right?
We've talked in
terms of institutions
and linking and
connecting institutions,
and we've talked a lot about
R&D and the R&D system,
but you know, from
the first class on,
Romer taught us
that the talent base
is a very critical
consideration in innovation.
And how do you build
up the talent base?
That's essentially our
set of tests today.
So, first, Norm Augustine.
I wanted to acquaint
you with Norm Augustine,
because in the science
and technology community,
he's known as St. Augustine.
And he is just an
incredible stand-up figure
on issues like the importance
of federal R&D investment.
He was chairman for
a lengthy period
of time of Lockheed Martin.
He won the President's
Medal of Technology.
Just a noted innovator,
himself, but also a true expert
on R&D issues, R&D policies.
Unfailingly helpful and willing
to volunteer for whatever task
the National Academies
or in many cases MIT,
or other organizations kind
of need help and advice
from a real senior
statesman, Augustine
has always been willing
to step up to the plate.
So he's kind of a
remarkable figure.
He led the rising against
the Gathering Storm report
back in 2000--
around the early
2000s timetable--
along with people
like Chuck Vest,
and a really noted
community of other experts,
that made the argument for a
very significant R&D increase
for the physical
science agencies.
Around that time, we
had been doubling NIH.
This report made the
case for doubling
the physical science-based
R&D areas, as well.
And it was a very influential
and important report.
He was one of the
real leaders of it,
and he played an important
role, along with Chuck Vest,
in helping persuade the
latest Bush administration--
hi, Karen-- to adopt
its recommendations.
So there was a period
of time of ongoing R&D
increases for the
physical science agencies.
So the report had a result.
In addition, he came back
and wrote this 2007 report
that just kind of
summarized the trouble
the US has got on the Science
and Technology education front.
So it's a 2007
snapshot, but it's still
a great little
collection of key points.
I'm just going to
summarize it very briefly.
Key finding number one was
that US children are not
prepared for the
21st century jobs,
and he has data
sets, as you know,
to back all these points up.
Children in school
are being taught
by teachers that are not
trained in the fields of math
and science that
they're teaching in,
which is a major underlying
problem in those students
picking up those fields.
US children are falling
behind their foreign peers
and counterparts in science
and technology areas.
The US K through 12
system just is not
performing in a way that's
comparable to many other
systems in the world.
And then, kind of a fourth point
is that US secondary education
isn't preparing students--
aside from the teacher problem--
for math, science, or
engineering majors,
and too few students--
this is the key point--
are majoring in
those disciplines
to yield the talent
base that we need
for technology-related careers.
And just to underscore
that, the US
ranks 17th among developed
nations in the proportion
of college students
receiving degrees in science
and engineering, and it
fell from third place
30 years before.
So these are dilemmas that the
US K through 12 system has.
So that's the K
through 12 story.
Then we shift to our
friend Paul Romer,
who we visited at the
outset of this class.
And as you know, he
taught at Stanford,
and then has been
teaching at NYU.
He's now chief economist
to the World Bank,
where he's been a fascinating
critic of economics and changes
and reforms that field
needs to go through.
But he came up with prospector
theory, and in a way,
what he's playing out here in
this pretty noted critique from
2000-- which is still
quite widely read--
his critique is, what
happened to the supply?
What are our supply breakdowns?
And then he's identified
those supply breakdowns
with higher education
institutions.
What are they
failing to deliver?
So the issue is that
the federal government
policies in science
and technology
tend to subsidize demand.
So in the private sector,
it's primarily tax incentives,
R&D tax credits.
And you promote
demand to encourage
science and engineering talent.
That policy approach, which
is astronomically expensive--
those are very
expensive policies--
that policy approach
doesn't inquire
about the supply response
that hopefully those subsidies
elicit.
And he goes back and argues that
the institutional arrangements
in universities, which are the
key institutions on the supply
side, are geared to meeting
the needs in a variety of ways.
So there needs to be
a new incentive system
to start to turn
around the supply side
because the current demand-based
tax incentive system just
isn't doing that.
So that's his overall frame.
In the 20th century, he argues,
rapid technological progress
drove unprecedented growth.
We know that argument.
And that was fostered by a
publicly supported system
of education.
So a steady flow
of trained talent,
trained in the
scientific method,
was a core policy that
evolved over time,
but that public policy approach
ignored the structures that
were supposed to deliver
that talent base,
i.e. the higher
education system,
and the incentives
and disincentives
within that higher education
structure that make that supply
side problematic.
So he would argue that
a governmental-- set
of governmental programs
to speed up innovation
gets thwarted by the
supply side problem,
in particular by the
higher education structure.
So government programs
focused on the demand and not
the supply side are going
to undermine the innovation
capabilities that we need.
Then he steps back and kind of
makes the innovation argument
for us.
He argues that
speeding up growth
is really the only
way we're going
to be able to cope with
the oncoming demographics
that we talked about when
we discuss the health care
innovation system.
He says that a conservative
estimate of the return on R&D
spending would be a 25% return.
There's arguments that that's
low, that it's well over 50%,
but let's accept his 25%.
His argument is that if you--
in theory, that if you
increased R&D spending
by 2% of GDP, voila, we'd
get a half percentage
point of growth.
Right?
In an economy that has
0.7% growth at the moment,
this is not a minor concept.
Right?
And the data would tend to--
it at least in
theory-- bear him out.
But then you run into
the barrier, right?
You have to look
at the full system,
and that means also
looking at the talent.
So just increasing the
R&D spending per se
doesn't address what he
calls the supply side,
and if the total number of
scientists and engineers
is fixed, then you limit--
and this is pure
prospector's theory,
as you remember from
our first class--
then you limit the biggest
input into innovation, and thus
into growth.
So by not expanding its supply
of scientists and engineers,
i.e. the talent
base, then the US
is limiting its growth capacity
by a pretty significant amount,
he argues, in economic terms.
So what's broken down?
What what's the heart
of the problem, here?
And this is a deep critique
of higher education, which
was highly controversial when
this came out and occasioned
a lot of criticism of Romer, but
it's hard to dispute his data,
and you will probably see
this from your own experiences
or the experiences of colleagues
in other universities.
So what's broken down on
the talent supply side?
He argues that universities
measure themselves
by their ability to select
top SAT scoring students.
In other words, they
measure themselves
by the quality input
they're able to attract,
not by their output.
There's no output
measures in this system.
They're competing
with each other
in things like US
News and World Report
on the students they attract,
not on the student outcomes
that they're creating.
So the traditional liberal
arts university, he argues,
faces little pressure to
respond to skills needs.
That economic messaging
that's inherent in the system
doesn't get translated back to
the higher education system.
So, meanwhile, the university
has a fixed investment
in its faculty that are
teaching in many areas--
including the sciences, but
obviously outside the sciences.
There is internal
pressure to maintain
the relative size of those
departments, which are--
they have invested in.
And that, in turn--
and we'll discuss
why in a minute--
but makes it more
difficult for students
to get science degrees.
So the science
faculties, he argues,
are happy to do what
they call "maintain
professional standards," i.e.
have a lot of lower grades.
And effectively what that does
is force out of the system
a tremendous amount of talent
because, again, they've
got fixed faculty sizes that
aren't coordinated with what
national talent
supply and needs may
be in science and technology.
There's no pressure
on universities
to address those
corresponding faculty
sizes to what the national
need may or may not be,
and therefore what's
happened is essentially
a bifurcated education system,
where sciences and engineering
students have one
grading system--
and as you all know, it's
a tougher grading system
at liberal arts universities
than other majors
in the social sciences
and humanities.
And you know, we know that there
is significant grade inflation
in the non-science,
non-engineering fields,
and that there is limited if any
grade inflation in the tougher
technical fields.
So that's what he's
talking about, here.
We maintain essentially
two grading standards,
the net effect of which is
to substantially discourage
entry of talent.
Now this is not in this report,
but the National Academy
of Engineering has
explored extensively
whether the people dropping
out of majors in engineering
are stronger or weaker
students than those staying in,
and they can't find any
basis for concluding
that they are any weaker.
In other words, we're
just driving talent out
of the system through
these mechanisms,
is Romer's argument.
So the supply problem--
by running this
bifurcating grading system
to drive out talent, to
maintain class size numbers
and make sure you don't have
to advise too many people--
the supply problem, in turn,
drives graduate school numbers,
because of course, undergraduate
degrees are prerequisites.
So how does US industry
cope with this?
Essentially what it's done--
and this is not bad--
it's encouraged
wholesale immigration
from all over the world
to fill the gap, which
it's done very systematically.
And that's why, for
example, industry
is so concerned about this
H-1B visa set of proposals
that the new administration
has recently proposed.
What are the
ramifications of that
in terms of access to
this talent supply?
Obviously, worldwide talent,
as we've talked about before,
is a very important
competitive advantage
for the United States.
But here we're in a
circumstance where
we're not creating parallel
opportunities for folks
in the US.
Moving on with Romer's
indictment of higher education,
because that's
really what it is,
he argues that PhD
programs train graduates
for the academy, but as all of
us in this room know, there's--
there's a complete oversupply
of PhDs in terms of what
the academy itself--
in other words, university
teaching-- actually requires.
So then we have to invent new
mechanisms to keep this talent
base around.
So we invent long, endless,
seven or eight-year graduate
programs.
England somehow manages to get
its PhDs done in three years.
Are they worse?
I don't know.
But we have a seven or
eight year old graduate--
eight year long graduate
education program,
and then we invent this
whole class of essentially
apprentices that
we call post-docs--
another substantial
army of people--
because there's no
space in the academy
to accommodate these people.
And yet the training
system is not
geared to the
location where there
are extensive opportunities--
whether in established
firms or startups-- which
is for industry because the
training system is really
geared for entering the academy,
not for entering industry.
And obviously, it tends to
focus more on basic than applied
for obvious reasons.
So this-- we're just
multiplying the problems here,
because the core input
institutions, i.e. higher
education, are not organized
around the skills problem
society has got.
That's Romer's indictment.
I had the privilege of working
with him on legislation,
and when this piece of
legislation came out,
there was considerable
interest on Capitol Hill,
and we're hearing all the time
on Capitol Hill in this era
about, we've got a
talent base problem,
and there was considerable
interest in the critiques
that Romer had
made of the system,
and how do you
change the system?
So, like other
senior staffers, I
read his stuff and
thought gee, how are we
going to turn this around?
We're going to have to
spend a fortune on creating
a massive new kind of fellowship
program across the country,
on top of what we already
have to encourage science
and engineering education.
We'll have to significantly
increase that--
maybe by a factor
of two or more.
How are we going to afford this?
Where's that money come from?
So I had a conversation
with Romer, and he said,
Bill, you have to think
like an economist here.
You have to bribe
the gatekeepers.
Right?
So I-- what are
you talking about?
And he said, look, figure
out who the gatekeepers are
in this entire
system and you bribe
them to make them turn
around their behavior.
So in this case, it's the
departments and the colleges
and universities as a whole--
it's their administrations.
Bribe them to get them
to change their numbers
because if they're not producing
enough scientists and engineers
net, then pay them to do this.
And by the way, bribery
is a heck of a lot
cheaper than creating a massive
new national fellowship,
and much more efficient.
So obviously, bribery is
not the apt term here,
but we ended up creating a
program at the National Science
Foundation, which Congress
passed, called The Step
Education Program,
which essentially
offers very significant
funding to departments
that guarantee they're going
to turn their numbers around,
and then present pathways by
which they're going to do so.
In other words, maybe
they offer much more one
on one kind of
tutorial attention
to keep students in
science and engineering.
Maybe they offer
fellowships with industry,
so you're guaranteed
summer employment
in an interesting,
relevant, applied field.
In other words, there
may be a whole slew--
and there turned
out to be a lot--
of ideas on how to begin to
turn those numbers around.
AUDIENCE: Are you talking
at the undergraduate level?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: I'm talking
at the undergraduate level.
AUDIENCE: I'm--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Go ahead, Max.
AUDIENCE: I'm kind of confused
how you can simultaneously
have a problem where you don't
have enough science engineering
workers but you also have
this army of post docs
that you don't know
what to do with.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Well, I mean
that's kind of the next stage
of the problem.
So his next piece, Max,
is innovation and graduate
education training.
So in other words, create
curricula that are relevant
not only to training
for the academy,
but curricula that are also
relevant to training for entry
in the industry,
and we're obviously
starting to see some of
these things materialize.
So a school like MIT-- but
it's by no means alone--
has a massive entrepreneurship
curriculum now available
in all of its schools.
This is not just a
business school program,
this is available
across the board,
and as you undergraduates know,
it's really quite accessible.
There's a substantial
number of business majors
who do a lot of
entrepreneurship--
business minors-- who do a
lot of entrepreneurship-esque
features in their education.
That's now much
better understood
by students going
to universities
as an option for what
their route ahead might be
than it was even 10 years ago.
So there has been
some change here,
but that's another
change he would make,
is to make the training
much more relevant to entry
into established firms
and to startup firms
at the graduate school level.
So overall, he would attempt to
use some federal funding here
to, in effect, redress the
imbalance in federal demand
and supply programs to
create an input of support
on the federal side--
on the supply side.
All right, so that's
two of our three.
You want to pause here?
Because this one's so
nicely controversial
that we could discuss it, and
you all can disagree with Romer
or indicate how correct he is.
Shall we do a quick pause?
Who's got this one?
You've got it, Max?
Do you want to quickly
summarize Romer?
Let's do Augustine, too.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Great.
AUDIENCE: All right, so
Augustine talks about how,
while as a lot of us know,
education in the United States
isn't great before
the university level.
So he gives a lot
of statistics, how
we're doing pretty poorly
in math and science
when compared to other
countries, how, for whatever
reason, it seems
that as people stay
within the American system,
the longer they stay in,
the poorer their ability to
compete with other countries
is.
So actually, I found
out one of the things--
some of the-- so America
has, in the past few decades,
been famous for the
concept of a brain drain,
where it would take the best and
brightest from other countries,
like India and China--
they would come over
here for our university
system, which is nice.
It's great for us.
It's not great for them,
but apparently this trend
is slowing as we find
out in this article,
because of some of our
more isolationist policies.
And I really appreciated
that he mentioned it,
because often a lot of
people tried to talk about,
isolationism is bad
because we are the world,
but this actually
gives a more concrete
reason for why
isolationism actually
causes some significant problems
to our innovation system
and to our economy.
So one of the questions
that I wanted to pose
is, how have all of our
educational institutions
at the university level
managed to maintain
their stature and their quality
despite the fact that lower--
lower level institutions
like high school and below
have been so sub par?
And can we implement some
of these characteristics
at these other levels?
Yeah, that's all.
AUDIENCE: I think
some of the answer
to that comes from just
the inequality across I
through 12 schools.
The US does have some
fantastic schools,
it's just who has
access to them,
and that tends to favor
certain groups over others,
and so instead of
being able to tap
into the full potential
talent pool that we have,
we're getting the
ones who happen
to live in a neighborhood
that goes to a good school,
or they have a nice magnet
school in their county.
So I think you could
also pose the question,
how much better could
American universities
be if they had their full
talent pool to choose from?
AUDIENCE: That's fair.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
like that point a lot,
because there are--
I mean, we definitely have
institutions-- higher parable
learning institutions,
universities-- in the United
States that are extremely
famous, extremely well known,
and extremely well respected.
You all are at one.
But there, if you look--
that doesn't mean that every
single university in the United
States is internationally
respected.
There's this huge spectrum
of the level of education
or the quality of education that
you can get at the university
level, and I think you're
exactly right-- that's
the same for K through 12.
It's just there's a huge span.
You just don't necessarily hear
about the really bad university
level educations.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: OK.
So--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: So following
up on that, then,
I've heard that one
of the main reasons
that we-- that, at least for
the K through 12 system, people
are-- or governments--
are unable to support
the schools that
are doing very well
and punish the ones
that are doing poorly.
Is there a way that we
could implement this
without jeopardizing the
educations of the people who
are already in these systems?
Because schools can't be treated
exactly like a free market,
because in a free
market, the worst case
is you buy a Zune instead
of an iPhone or iPod
and well, OK, that
kind of sucks.
But it doesn't
suck nearly as much
as it does for the
kid who has to go
through a year
with a bad teacher,
and sure, maybe the
teacher gets fired after,
but that's still a year
that this kid has lost,
and that sets them
behind, and those--
that impact can last for the
rest of this person's life.
So-- that was a really
long question, I'm sorry.
So to phrase that more
simply, how can we
implement some sort
of free market style
without that inherent
impact on a kid's life?
AUDIENCE: Well, I think just
to reorganize the question
and some decision making,
why are you assuming it's
the teacher's fault that,
in a central city school,
they don't do well, right?
Usually it's people who
really, really care,
but the students
aren't ready to learn.
Because like-- I
forget the quote,
but it's combined as
like a parachute that
needs to be opened to
receive information.
So I think it's a
more complex issue, is
the point I'm trying to make.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
the first time
I've looked into this, because
there's a special class called
by Tom Malone, and
I think we're going
to be talking about
the future of war
next week where he
talks a lot about,
now we're in a distributed
kind of network system.
And we kind of get
through hierarchy systems.
And so like in that
class, we posited like,
you know like YouTube
has all the videos
and is created by
a ton of people.
We talked about like what if
somebody made like a YouTube
for education, where the best
teachers would get the most
views.
And you could quantify
that and pay them
really high salaries, right?
So you'd get like NBA,
and NBA player salaries
for doing really great
content and a lot of people
would access it.
And pretty much the
whole population
would be taught by the best
teachers in the country
or in the world.
And then you'd have
the personal touch,
like Khan Academy, where it's
like online for some subjects
or like [INAUDIBLE]
in a really good way.
And then in the
actual class system,
you are going through the
kind of like the issues
and figuring out
what your errors are
so you can learn better.
So I think that's an
interesting incentive.
The thing though is
like I think this
is more of the
dynamics of the market
but the gatekeepers problem than
it is like an education problem
or even like the
pipeline issues.
If our incentive system
is to get the best people
to the school and
not care what happens
after, that's kind of like
a screwed up system, right?
It's like if your whole-- yeah.
Like we're not
focusing on making
the best students in the world.
We're focusing on finding
the smartest people up
to that point that they become
students at our university.
And our reputation is based on
getting the smartest people up
to here.
So it doesn't matter if you
have a screwed up economy.
There's always going
to be a really top 1%.
Like, it doesn't matter,
because like most
of the people at the school will
come from all different kinds
of backgrounds.
And they will never
say, most likely
it was because of their school.
Like if they come from
a poor background,
they're going to say, you
know, I just went online,
or went to the library, or I
learned from the best people
in their books.
That was even like a response.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Well, you
introduced the online idea.
And we're going to jump on that
kind at the end of the class.
So we should come
back to that Martin.
AUDIENCE: Which I definitely
think is an interesting idea.
I think it's easy
to frame the access.
All you need is an
internet connection
and basically everyone
has a cell phone.
AUDIENCE: You know,
we'll get to is later.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: And there
are pros and cons on this too.
AUDIENCE: It's also
overdone, right?
There's like a ton of businesses
and a ton of organizations
I've seen try to do it.
And like why haven't
they figured it out.
It's probably like a policy,
incentives, power issue.
AUDIENCE: Yes, I think,
just thinking about it
from like also an
international perspective,
I think a problem in the US
is also like the whole respect
thing for teachers.
Like I think especially
at the middle school
or the high school, like the
public education system, maybe
there's not as much respect
for being a teacher.
Whereas like maybe in
Sweden, or like China,
like being a
professor, a teacher
is really well respected and
considered a really prestigious
job.
So I think that's like
some systemic issue that's
also kind of preventing maybe
the top talent from going
into teaching, not necessarily
at the higher education level.
I think there is a lot of
really intelligent academics
in that space.
But definitely,
towards the beginning
where children are like
really starting out
their educational careers,
and that's the fundamental.
And also from what I
know like in Europe,
they start kind of
specializing pretty early
on in like high school
into what kind of track
they want to pursue later on.
So I feel like that could be
an interesting way that they're
kind of promoting, for
example, engineering
or math or STEM related
technical expertise.
Like they're really fostering
that from early stage.
So that really helps
and sets up the students
to advance later on.
Whereas like a lot
of students here
they get like kind of basic
introduction to everything.
But then once they get
to engineering classes,
some people aren't
very prepared.
AUDIENCE: Actually regarding
the first part of what
you said about the
teachers and trying
to incentivize the best
talent in our country
to become a teacher, that's
actually my second question.
I was going to ask, well,
how could we incentivize them
outside of pay?
Because I've heard that
the US education system
is at an all time high for
paying, for the amount of money
that we spend per
student in the classroom.
So clearly just throwing money
at this problem is not enough.
So what can we do?
Is there a way we can
either change the culture
or some other aspect?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I think one of
the problems with the US system
is that it's kind of punitive.
Where there's like
mass or firing, sorry,
mass firing things,
whereas teachers
that are not like performing up
to a grade just be like let go.
And that's kind of
bad on the students
because there's a
lot of turnover.
But I think in other, we can
maybe borrow from another model
where other cities, I
think what comes to mind
is Shanghai has this program
where a lot of teachers
or professors that are
not performing as well
are partnered with an educator
that has more experience
or has better understanding
of how to reach the students.
And they have this kind of
like collaborative model,
where they bring up
the teachers instead
of trying to just fire
them or like dock their pay
or something.
Which I think is
probably something
that would be ultimately
better for like the students
in general as well.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: So Max, why
don't we move on now to Grover.
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah, sure.
That most anybody is going
to be closing points here.
AUDIENCE: I just
want to bring up
the point that was made
in one of the papers,
I forget if it's this one,
about having access to looking
at like seeing engineers.
Yeah, like, if you're in a
community where you've never
got to interact with engineers
or somebody who does STEM,
you're going to see
it a certain way,
especially since when
you look at the subject,
it's so dry in the classroom
versus what you actually
end up doing.
I think that's also
a big component,
especially once you structure
who you want to become, right?
Because at that
age, you're trying
to figure out where you
want to be a role model.
Yeah, like an
example, Steve Jobs
got to work when
he was 12 at HP.
And he said that
was the thing that
led him to work on tech,
because his whole background,
his dad was a mechanic.
It also made him realize what
a good company was, because he
saw how the employees are
treated and it made them see,
oh, this is why having the
right company culture matters.
That's a lesson he
learned at 12 that led him
to change how he saw his life.
AUDIENCE: I think on my
end in terms of Augustine,
there is a point he made
about American exceptionalism
and our focus on finding
spectacular talent,
not just on good talent.
And so, I remember
a few weeks ago,
I mentioned the
quote where the good
becomes the enemy of the great.
And maybe in the
education system,
the great is the
enemy of the good.
And perhaps we're sort of
not doing a good enough job
of supporting people who
do a fine job at pursuing
engineering and
science because we're
focused on finding the
innovators, the Edisons,
the Jobs, the
Gates of the world.
So to create a support
infrastructure,
people who might do a
fine job at carrying out
their functions I
think is ultimately
the task of the education
system at the lower level.
And then at the university
level of cultivating that talent
to really create
spectacular innovation.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, to
add on to that point,
I think, yeah, they
definitely prefer the Edisons,
but I think that was
more in the paper
already talked about
breakthrough ideas.
I think this paper
was more about,
we have a pipeline issue that
we need these kind of employees
so that these fields
stay in the US.
And they weren't
looking for Edisons.
They were looking for
niche, like you know,
you want to discipline and can
move ahead and get that job.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: So
let's shift over to Romer.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
you're just like, oh,--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Well,
we're leading into it.
So we might as well.
That's your pipeline boy.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Yeah, so regarding
the pipeline, Romer
decided to focus mostly on
the undergraduate and graduate
institutions and
trying to figure out
how you can increase the supply
of the talented scientists
and engineers that exist in
the American innovation system.
So one of the
questions that I saw
was posed pretty interesting,
someone was asking
what metrics or
measures could you
use to actually evaluate these
new scientists and engineers
as they're coming
into these fields
and how can you train
them to come into,
to be prepared to go into
either industry or academia.
AUDIENCE: I mean, the first
thing that comes to mind
is like professional engineer
exams that exist already.
That's kind of
like the standard.
AUDIENCE: Those aren't
required, are they?
AUDIENCE: No, not usually.
Well some companies will
require you to get them.
It's generally just like a--
AUDIENCE: It's a nice little--
AUDIENCE: Thing you can check.
But like, I don't
think it's very like,
before I came to MIT, I'd
never even heard of it.
So I don't know if
that's something
that carries a ton of weight.
But I don't know.
I don't really like the idea
of using standardized tests
as a measure of competency.
But I mean if you're
trying to talk
about a large group of people
there is no feasible way
to do it other than that.
If you want to talk
about all the engineers
that are entering the
workforce, like, unfortunately,
numbers are kind of like
the only way to do it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, you
can't [INAUDIBLE]
recommendation letters.
Just like everyone can find
someone that likes them.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Might
there be a reason why
such extensive licensing exams
exist in the medical field
and not in the engineering
or life sciences fields?
AUDIENCE: I mean, it's
because it's probably
easy to mess up costs a lot
of money if you mess up.
So you don't want
people to mess up.
But it's pretty easy to
mess up in engineering.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but people don't
die and don't get lawsuits.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: I mean, to
the personal engineering
exams, to what extent does
accreditation of universities
already attempt to fill
that role that you know,
if you're accepted
into and graduate
from an accredited
engineering program,
you already have that
check mark, that like, OK.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So the PE exam is basically
just a feather in your cap.
It doesn't really-- or I
don't know, a little stamp
on your resume.
Doesn't really--
AUDIENCE: But is there
a fault with the way
that we give that accreditation
to things right now?
Is it becoming more meaningless?
If we're graduating maybe
an engineer from one school
that is far more capable
than another school
that has the same like stand?
AUDIENCE: I mean, you could
make the same argument
with like any profession, right?
Like, to go into Stephanie
as example of medicine.
So if you have someone who
comes from the Harvard vs. name
somewhere you don't
like, Harvard.
Yeah, then you can see
a difference in quality.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Let me
raise a question, [INAUDIBLE]..
It's harder for you
folks at MIT to see this
because it's obviously
predominantly science
and engineering.
But let me ask Sanam
and Steph, how much
do you see the great
inflation in a classic,
you know, high quality,
liberal arts school
between social science,
humanities kinds
of majors and science
and engineering majors?
And Lily, you came from
one of those institutions.
Please join in.
Is this real?
Is the problem that
Romer is seeing here,
is this a real issue?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] econ
major at Wellesley College.
AUDIENCE: Not at
Wellesley, there
is a definite sense of
grade inflation there.
AUDIENCE: It is not a sense.
It is a policy.
AUDIENCE: Yes, it's a policy.
It's an actual policy.
Instituted, grade inflation.
But in terms of the disparity
between the humanities,
social sciences and STEM fields,
I think there is definitely--
generally, there's the idea
that like the STEM fields are
more difficult. So recently
we had this policy where
the first semester of your
college year shadow graded,
so you're not
actually given grades.
And that kind of resulted
in a lot of people
entering the STEM
fields [INAUDIBLE]..
And that was something
that obviously
the humanities professors
and social sciences
were very against.
Because if the
students coming in
were automatically going
to anything outside
of their department,
they kind of ended up
staying there because
the faculty are great.
So they would continue
in that program.
So that was kind of
an imbalance that
occurred in the recent years.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: So
in a way, exactly what
Romer's talking about.
Interesting.
Lily, what was your point?
AUDIENCE: I was a science major.
And I made A's in
every single class
I took outside of my own major.
And not As.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: What
were you thinking, Lily?
[LAUGHING]
AUDIENCE: We started--
I wanted to do science.
We started out with
almost 600 students
in the first semester
chemistry course.
And by the second
semester chemistry,
so this is chemistry majors,
biology majors, and engineering
majors, all have to take that.
They also have to take a
second semester of chemistry.
And there were
probably less than 400
by the second semester.
So it was a huge weed out class.
AUDIENCE: How many were
there in the beginning?
AUDIENCE: Over
600, just over six.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Most
schools have notorious weed
out classes that
essentially frustrate
the ambitions of
a lot of students,
particularly in the premed area.
Obviously notorious, shall
we say organic chemistry is
the [INAUDIBLE].
So this is a dilemma when
you've got a societal need
and you've got the
institutions that
are supposed to deliver
your talent base
just operating off a completely
different set of incentives
than what the society may be.
That's the core of
Romer's argument here.
And another part of his argument
is, the numbers are not that
far off.
In other words, if we
just got the people who
wanted to major in science,
engineering, and mathematics
to stay in the field, you know,
lots of the numbers problems
get a heck of a lot better.
But that 40% or
more dropout rate
out of those fields
that typically
occurs at the undergraduate
level is highly problematic.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: I think they've been
waiting longer if you want to.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I
couldn't see your hands.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so I started
to wonder about a couple
of these choke points,
like where actually people
are starting to drop out of
these science and engineering
fields.
I know we identified kind
of these weed out classes.
And I think kind of looking from
like who declares, who ends up
finishing, I think
you could probably,
as a whole identify kind of
gradient deflation in a couple
of these classes is like very
complicated, kind of weed out
classes as reasons why
people start to kind of leave
the field and migrate out.
And I think it might
be indicative to sort
of each institution kind of
where these dropout points are.
But I think en masse,
you can kind of
take these like first year
classes as kind of places
where students
start to fall off.
And then, is it actually--
so is it part of kind of this
college exploratory process,
like kind of figuring
out what you want to do?
It's like how you phrase it.
As like, you started
as a chemistry major.
But maybe you end up gravitating
towards social science
because you don't really like
the way that weed out class
is structured?
Or is it part of this
indicative problem that we have,
where like we can't
graduate and sustain
the people who are actually
interested in these fields?
And so I wonder if like, you
know, just because you know,
we're not graduating
enough, is it
because these
classes are actually
structured in a way that
prevents people graduating?
Or is it like part of this--
kind of the way that we
brand your college experience
is like you're supposed
to be able to explore
and kind of transition
in and out, especially
in that first year
and experience things.
And my second point
was like, there's
a little bit of a
difference I would
say in kind of STEM fields,
even in that first year.
Because I know a lot of
colleges offer the opportunity
to use high school
classes to sort
of test out of those first
year, maybe even those weed
out classes.
And then, it's sort
of an added bonus
as well, because you end up
testing out of these classes,
so you use up less semesters
to finish your degree.
And so I know that can
be like a big reason
and incentive for
students to sort of choose
other universities,
because they're like,
oh, I'll only be in this
school for three years
if I go to maybe the
state school over here,
rather than staying in
school for four years
at a different university.
And like, is there
a way to identify
sort of the relative
quality of education
in kind of testing out of
that first year of engineering
classes and then finishing in
three versus going for four.
Because I feel like
if you can graduate
a whole bunch of people, maybe
in that three year time span
without like a marginal decrease
in quality of education,
we can start looking more
to those programs as well.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Max,
how about a close up
point on the Romer.
AUDIENCE: So evidently,
Romer is evidence
that the education problem
is unbelievably complicated.
Throwing money at
the issue has not
been sufficient to
actually solve it.
And there are issues
with the quality,
as was being talked about, the
weed out courses that exist,
grade inflation and
deflation, standardizing.
So, such an issue will take--
it's going to take a
very long time to solve.
But all of the issues
that he has pointed out,
they are definitely solvable.
I'd say the main barrier
between us and now and a future
where these issues are
solved would be the--
would be just
politics, just trying
to get people to agree to
these different programs that
would focus more
on the education
and less on the incentives
of those teaching.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: I
think part of what's
interesting about
Romer's argument
is that he takes the theory that
we've got a talent supply, set
of talent supply
issues, and then he
attempts to figure out what
are the more specific barriers
to that supply, and then do an
institutional analysis of why
these barriers are in effect
created at the higher education
system.
And then interestingly,
he attempts
to take three or four
public policy fixes that
could actually address these.
And I do think that both
his article and the Step
Program from the National
Science Foundation
created based on the
legislation that he
recommended that
Congress passed,
and that NSF implemented.
It was never implemented
with the funding
scale that was really needed to
make a significant difference.
But it started to send a
different set of signals
about supply of science
and technology talent
to the university
system and did I
think have an effect over time.
But these issues are
obviously still with us.
So let me move
quickly from Romer
to our next reading
with Richard Freeman.
And he kind of takes
us to the next level
of the supply problem.
Richard Freeman is a quite
famous labor economist
at the school up the street.
And he's famous for his wide
range and variety of hats.
As you can see, he has
a wonderful collection.
So he looks at a
different problem.
You know does globalization
threaten the--
and its movement in
science and engineering,
threaten US economic leadership?
And you know, his--
I'll kind of summarize
his four key points here.
You know, the
underlying issue is
that changes in the global
job market for science
and engineering, science and
entering workers, S&E workers
are eroding US dominance in
science and engineering, which
in turn diminishes a strong
comparative advantage
that the US historically held
since the end of World War II
as we've been talking
about in the past.
And he makes four
underlying points
in kind of looking
at this dimension.
In other words, we have
Augustine's critique of K
through 12.
We have Romer's critique of
the higher education system.
And then Richard
Freeman kind of tells us
what the economic
implications are
of failing to maintain that
leadership base in science
and engineering talent.
So his point is that the
share of the world science
and engineering graduates
in the US is in decline.
And look, others are
understanding this model
and moving to fill it.
Second, that the job
market has worsened
for younger workers in
science and engineering fields
relative to many
other high level
occupations, which
in turn discourages
US students in those fields.
Now he's writing
this at the time when
a startling proportion
of MIT students
and other science
and engineering
graduates in other
schools were going
into the financial sector,
financial services,
and consulting.
Some of that since he
wrote has turned around.
In other words, there
has been an emergence
at MIT of interest in
startups and entrepreneurship,
to the tune that some 20%
to 25% of those of you
when you graduate, your
graduating classmates
will go into those
fields in a way
that community moved out
of financial services
post 2008 crash and
moved over to what
may be a really important
kind of career shift
in terms of the
country's future.
But that hadn't occurred yet
by the time he's writing this.
So in other words,
the extremely high pay
available to those
entering financial services
and consulting drained
talent out of the system
is his point within the US.
And then, you know, countries
like China and India
found that they could compete
with the US in high tech
by starting to train
substantial numbers of science
and engineering specialists.
In other words, they could
leapfrog, right, and in effect
go to substantial parts
of their economy being
quite high tech, even while
they were working on bringing up
what's in effect a developing
world economy in the meantime.
So they hit on this model.
And it's a really
important model.
But that in turn had an
effect on kind of US dominance
in this field.
I mean, it's not a bad thing
for the world to get better,
but it doesn't have an effect
on the US comparative advantage.
So to ease the adjustment
to a less dominant position
in science and engineering
with the corresponding economic
ramifications for US economic
growth and competitiveness,
the US is going to
have to develop,
he argues, new labor
market and R&D policies
that start to try to change the
science and engineering talent
numbers.
So we're going to have to
step into the marketplace.
And you know, this is
where Romer's thinking
would come to bear.
So let me let me move
to Goldin and Katz
and they further talk about the
societal ramifications for what
we're doing in higher
education, right?
We've talked a bit
about this before.
And they also teach
up the street.
And their book, The Race
Between Education and Technology
was really a quite
important one.
I think it's held up well
since it came out in 2009.
But I had you read a short
version, a Milken Institute
review piece that came out
before they put their book out.
But I do recommend
the book to you.
The gap between wages of
educated and less well educated
workers has been
growing since 1980,
and this expanding
wage inequality
has characterized the
US since that time.
So we're becoming a much
more polarized society
and the lines are drawn
on education lines, right?
And this is, we've
talked about this before,
but this is David
Otter's barbell problem,
that our society is increasingly
looking like a barbell.
And we've got on
one bell, a growing
and successful upper middle
class that has the education
and is able to
use that education
to capture that wealth,
a thinning middle,
and a growing lower end
services economy that's
less well-paid
and less well off,
to which substantial
portions of the middle
are now being shunted.
And we can start to see this
polarization in our economy
in pretty sharp terms.
And that's what Katz and
Goldin are writing about.
The wage inequality narrowed
in the United States
significantly from about
1910 through the 1950s.
Then it stabilized
until about the 1980s.
And then it's grown
since that time.
Why?
And they argue--
I'll attempt to just
paint you a quick picture.
But they argue that there
is a race between education
and technology, and that
what happened in the US
was that there is an
ever-growing curve
of technology knowledge since
the Industrial Revolution.
And we've talked
about this previously,
but I'll reiterate it.
That an economy
requires, in other words,
it requires an
ever-growing level
of technological sophistication.
And the genius of
the US system was
to create mass higher
education, which we did,
first through the
Land Grant Act.
Of course that created MIT.
That was the big
enabler for MIT.
It had initial funding in 1861.
Its graduating class marched
off to the Civil War.
There was no revenue base.
In 1862, Congress passed
the Land Grant College Act
and suddenly there
was a revenue stream
to make up for the loss of
talent, loss of the tuition
base.
So that saved MIT.
But created public
higher education
really across the country
in every state at the time
extended to new ones.
So we created that system of
mass higher education, really
through the Land Grant
College Act in 1862.
No other country had
done anything like that.
So we created a talent
base that stayed ahead
of the technological
curve, right?
And that's what you want.
You want your talent
base to stay ahead
of the increased sophistication
of technology in the economy,
so that that talent base can
keep moving that curve up,
right?
And that they
benefit each other.
And then, what Katz
and Goldin point out,
is that in the mid
'70s, we level that off.
AUDIENCE: Was there something
that caused it in particular?
Let me get to that
in a minute, Martin.
But we do need to
come back to that.
I don't think we
fully understand
the dimensions of what was
happening at that point.
But there are some thoughts.
So what happened was
that the people that
continue to ride
this curve, they
stayed up with the
technology curve.
Those that fell off
fell behind the curve
and their incomes
correspondingly suffered.
That's the case
that they're making.
and that these people
got left off the curve
and couldn't keep riding
up to take advantage
of the economic gains.
So you've got a smaller
number of people you know,
riding this curve up.
They get the gains.
Whereas in this period of
time between 1910 and 1950,
everybody at least, a very
large part of the population
was riding that curve
and able to benefit.
So that's the great creation
of this mass middle class
in the United States.
And the data tends
to bear this out.
So that's their essential
equation here on what happened.
Again, they argue that
technological advance
is the key to growth.
We know that from this class.
And that the ebb and flow of
wage equality and inequality
is very much
related to the skill
set you've got to keep riding
that technological curve.
Now look, if anything the growth
in that technological curve
has just gotten steeper
with the development of all
these information technologies.
You know heaven forbid,
a next generation
if you don't have
coding skills, right?
With the entry of
significant amount
of artificial intelligence
in the economy.
If you're going to stay up, you
really need that skill base.
Otherwise you're going
to get left behind.
So, you know, that's
essentially their picture
of what's been going on here.
Let me-- that stagnation of
education levels around '73
or so coincides with the
period of economic challenge
from Japan that we talked about
in the second manufacturing
class.
That's the period where
the Rust Belt gets created.
So the US had been on an
ever rising economic curve.
Suddenly its growth rate
fell to the 2% range
from its historic 3% range
and its productivity rate
strides growth as
we've talked about,
its productivity rate
fell to the 1% range.
So that means there's less
real wealth in the economy.
And that may, Martin, in
answer to your question, that
may have had something
to do with our ability
to keep financing
ever-growing education.
Remember that the public
universities provide
80% of higher education.
That's the key
component of the system.
You know, places like MIT
are all very well and good,
but that's a 20% share.
The core talent base are getting
trained in public universities.
And other things
have been happening
to those public universities.
So they're competing
at the state level
for funding with
two major factors.
One is Medicaid,
which the states bear
a very large portion of
and the other is prisons.
Because we have a
massive prison growth.
And the annual cost
of prisoners is
much higher than putting
people in higher education.
You begin to wonder
where your priorities are
when you think about that.
So there have been
increased pressure
on state budgets that
correspond with that '73
to like 1990 and 1991, kind of
economic decline period that
may account for it.
Now the Obama administration
understood this curve well.
And Obama was fluent with
Katz and Goldin's work.
And they made a major effort
to increase Pell grants
and increase the availability
of higher education funding.
So interestingly, there was an
improvement in the last decade
in some of these numbers.
Some of that was
driven by the fact
that jobs are a disaster
in 2007 and 2008.
So people tended to spend that
time if they could afford it
in higher education locations.
So that was some
of that going on.
But overall, the
Administration made an attempt
to try and get those
numbers turned around
and they're a bit better.
And the public
universities themselves
understood their
mission and realized
that they're going to have to
increase their employment base
in order to accomplish this.
All right, so that's
Katz and Goldin.
I mean there's other important
points there, but that's key.
And then I want to do--
you know, we've talked
about higher education
as though it's
the only way here.
But I wanted to introduce some
controversy into the debate.
So William Baumol, very noted
economist, taught at Princeton,
more recent years have been
teaching at NYU, you know,
a remarkable analyst.
And he's written in
many different kind
of economics fields.
Baumol does this
NBER, National Bureau
of Economic Research
kind of work paper
that just nails
the whole system.
So I thought we'd introduce
a little controversy
in today's class by putting
his piece in front of us.
He argues that
breakthrough innovation
comes from independent
inventors and entrepreneurs,
that large firms concentrate
on incremental innovation.
We've talked about
this bit before.
And this conclusion
is what is startling.
Education for the mastery
of science knowledge
aids incremental advance,
doesn't necessarily
prepare you for doing
the breakthrough,
entrepreneurial side.
So his point then, is that kind
of standard science education
may actually impede
breakthrough thinking.
And that large firm R&D requires
scientists and engineers
that are educated
in the established
fields and the established
analytical methods
and that successful innovators
and entrepreneurs often
lack that standard preparation.
And that that may get
them out of the box
of incremental advance into
kind of new territories.
And he points out that
we don't have a system
and we don't understand
breakthrough learning.
How do we educate
for innovation?
We have no real clue
on how to do that.
And that procedures for
incremental learning
do seem to work.
But we don't know how to educate
for the innovation side--
of the innovation
system, who's got what.
He points out the Proctor &
Gamble with 7,500 scientists,
1,250 PhDs, I mean, these
kinds of totals start
to dwarf the size of faculties
at MIT and Harvard and Stanford
and so forth.
You know, with 22
research centers,
P&G has in 12 different
nations, that's
a pretty amazing talent base.
What are they up to?
Remember that when you look
at R&D combined, industry
spans about 70% of the total
spending on R&D. Of course,
we know that that's
D, not R, right?
But industry has got
about a 70% share.
The federal government,
about 30% share, that's R.
So that gives us an idea
of the different size
of the establishments
in the R&D side.
So we know that industry
employs some 64%
of scientists and
engineers, right?
So industry has got
that talent base.
And he notes that
critical breakthrough
historical innovator figures
like Watt, Whitney, Fulton,
Morris, Edison, the Wright
brothers, Wozniak, Jobs, Gates,
Dell, have no college
degrees, and frankly,
limited scientific training.
AUDIENCE: Wait, Jobs
had a college degree.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yes,
he had a college degree.
No, he didn't finish Reed.
AUDIENCE: No, he left
in the first year.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Yeah, he left.
He left after a year or two.
AUDIENCE: I thought he
went somewhere else.
AUDIENCE: He stayed.
He stayed with Reed and
just dropped in on classes,
but it wouldn't count
as getting a degree.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
He was studying things
like calligraphy that
actually turned out
to be incredibly
important for him.
AUDIENCE: I mean, that's
the quote example,
he went a lot of
classes [INAUDIBLE]..
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
And he spent a year in India.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, he did a
lot of interesting things.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: So Baumol's
point is progress requires--
we shouldn't underestimate this.
It's not that one side is bad.
Progress requires both
breakthrough radical advance
and incremental advance.
And an example, which I've
used before with you all, you
know, if you're flying
across the Atlantic Ocean,
the Wright brothers,
you know, motorized kite
is a terrific, radical
break through advance.
But I'd rather take
the 787, product
of 10 decades worth of
incremental advances when
I go across the ocean.
So both are really
important here.
You've got to do both pieces.
But, a disproportionate
share of the breakthroughs do
seem to come from kind
of independent inventors
or entrepreneurs.
And large firms tend to
specialize on the incremental,
in part because they want to
break up their own business
models, right?
They've got established
business models.
They want to contribute
to those business models
rather than wreck their
existing business model.
So that's part of the
economic motivation here.
But education for
incremental advance
may well be different as Baumol
points out, than education
for the novel advance.
And incremental
improvement may well
require a much greater
mastery of demanding
science and technology
information than the novel
idea.
So both are essential.
But then he posts the
critical question,
how do you educate for the
original and novel idea
generation?
So we've got three new
stories on the table here.
And let's start off
discussion, and then we'll
take a break in a bit.
First, we've got
Richard Freeman.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
I wanted to make
some strides actually
on a point to that Baumol made
in our conversation of three
months since Baumol was
the one who cited P&G
as an innovative research
and development firm
with a lot of PhDs.
One of you posed the
question about Freeman.
This paper lauds
the relationship
in the United States between
firms and university research.
For multi-national
companies, what incentives
do they have to promote US
innovation leadership, even
when they may be based in
the US when they operate
in so many different countries?
So at the heart of
this question is,
why do we need to
invest in America
if it is that the private
sector is not investing and has
no rational self
interest to invest in us
from an economic perspective?
That is the implication
of this question.
AUDIENCE: I don't
think it's like--
I think that we look at
it one dimensionally.
You have to look at it,
like, think about it
like an individual, right?
Like you're going to be a baby.
There's a whole
gestation period.
Then there's a time
period where you're trying
to grow as an individual.
And then there's one when you're
ready to get to it, right?
And like you're very useful.
So for industry like,
they can't really
handle this whole
gestation period,
you know, one to 18
years old period.
But they can handle
it after, when
you're ready to go and do
a little ramp up skills.
But to do a whole thing
is pretty difficult.
AUDIENCE: That's an
interesting answer.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: I'd add too
that the US has an extremely
decentralized labor market.
So there is a huge disincentive
for employers in the United
States to offer training.
Because they offer training,
which can be quite expensive,
investing in you, that in
turn equips you to move on.
So often another
employer will buy you out
for a lower margin with
the educational costs.
But the employer who
invested in your education
won't be able to
match that increment.
So why should they
invest in employees
if the talent is
going to go elsewhere?
And countries like Germany have
a much more established set
of apprenticeship rules and
much more heavily unionized,
80% unionized in the
manufacturing sector.
They have been able to create
an apprenticeship system that's
much more enduring
and employer tied.
That creates tremendous
encouragement for employers
to provide lots of skills
training to its employees.
Indeed, it's really a part of
the German education system.
We have never really
been able, because we
have such a decentralized and
almost laissez faire labor
market, we've never
been able to create
significant incentives for
employers to provide education.
It's a deep structural
problem in our system.
And you know it's one we're
going to probably have
to figure out how to deal with.
We have created a whole
system of community colleges.
But the burden is
on the employee
to go back and get
that education.
We make that pretty inexpensive.
AUDIENCE: Going back here
about the gatekeeper thing.
Couldn't we just bribe them?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Bribe the employees?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Oh, no.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Bribe the employers?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Right, we could.
AUDIENCE: The education,
how much is it?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: I'm
sure it's not cheap, right?
AUDIENCE: Damn it.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
But in other words,
could we create an
incentive for employers
to provide the education
system, even if they weren't
able to retain their workers.
And what would that cost?
So maybe the feds would
pick up that cost.
So in a way, the
community college system
is a way of the
government picking up that
Cost and share it
with the employee.
Because employers can't
take the risk mitigating.
I kind of jumped into
the discussion here.
I want to give it
back to you, Steph.
Get me out of this.
AUDIENCE: I think that's--
who posed this question?
Yeah, I think you're right.
I mean it really gets at the
heart of all three readings.
And I think, in
particular, let me
see if I can parse for a quote
here from one of the readings.
Actually it was in Freeman's
reading, when he quoted
Derek Bok, who is the founder--
I think--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
President of Harvard.
AUDIENCE: President of Harvard.
And now the graduate school
of education at Harvard
has a center for innovative
learning named after Derek Bok.
And he claimed towards
the end of the piece,
or rather he was cited
towards the end of the piece
as saying that other countries
are facilitating our enterprise
model.
And if, I think it's really
meritous of consideration,
that if our education
system is not supporting
the production of scientists
and engineers, and firms are you
know sort of ready and
happy to get employees
from other countries or to
move to other countries,
that we're effectively
shooting ourself in a foot,
by participating in free market
principles for education.
Because we can't
provide the labor force
and we can't support
the labor force and we
can't support
incentives financially.
So at the end of the day,
we're preventing ourselves
on all fronts from
innovating, which
I think is a really important
consideration that merits sort
of being honest with ourselves,
as not only a society,
but also as you know
a political economy.
AUDIENCE: Something
throughout all the readings
that I have not understood.
How is it that we're spending
so much on education,
like so much money per
student, yet teachers
are not getting any
of it and the students
don't have very high
quality educations.
Where's the money going?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
Max, I think that
was addressed by Norman
Augustine's piece
very slightly when he talked
about the appropriation
of funds and where
spending goes.
Specifically Augustine
cited that 61%
of education budgets
in schools tend
to go to education
spending sort of broadly.
And that it actually
tends to trend downward
for a lot of school
districts who
focus on other extracurricular
activities like sports.
And I think he made
that very brief note
about the role of
American culture
in those funding priorities.
And I think that also
was a consideration
of mine in reading this
piece in conjunction
with the Freeman piece.
Like, what is the role that
our own vision of ourselves
and how we want to
educate our children
informs our policy decisions
and spending down the line.
And you brought the
point earlier that
how is it that we
don't have-- or that we
have too many jobs that
we don't have enough jobs
but have too many PhDs, but
then not have enough PhDs.
And I think that the point
that Bill was trying to make
is that we have
too many PhDs who
are trying to go into academia,
but not enough PhDs who
are prepared for industry
and not enough PhDs generally
to go into industry.
Does that clear
things up a little?
AUDIENCE: That clears
things up a lot.
AUDIENCE: OK.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Yeah, I think I'd
add an additional point there.
And this is a complex one that
you are free to disagree with.
But, when we created the higher
education system in the US,
obviously it occurred over
the process of centuries.
And when the federal government,
during and following World War
II, came into a very
significant support
role for that system in
addition to the states,
that was already a quite
competitive system.
And as someone who has spent
substantial amount of time
with MIT's top
administrators, I can tell you
that MIT and other universities
do exactly the same thing,
they watched their university
competitors like hawks.
They know exactly
what they're up to.
They know exactly what
they're spending on what.
They know exactly what their
competition models are.
They're looking very hard at how
MIT will compete all the time.
It is an extremely
competitive model.
It drives a tremendous search
for talent at the faculty level
as well as the student level.
And that talent base is
very well compensated.
And that is a core way by
which you compete for talent
in a competitive system.
We don't really have a
competitive system in the K-12
public education system.
It's essentially a
monopoly-based socialist model
frankly.
And you know part of the entry
of charter school legislation
was to introduce a
competitive model into the K
through 12 system.
Now there's a big debate as
to how well that's worked.
But I think it's
fair to say overall,
it's added a significant dose
of competition into that system.
And
You could look at
competition in health care.
And you could
competition and you
know other large government
supported systems too.
But you know, when we
came out of World War II,
we created a socialist model
for caring for veterans
in federally owned hospitals.
And we fit into what was
already a competitive space
by supporting students, who
in turn were given funding
and they could go.
They could take the
money with them.
Didn't go to the
universities to fund them.
So it's introduction of
more competitive models
here may have something
to do with improvements
in higher education.
At least that was the
concept behind introducing
charter schools.
AUDIENCE: Could I
ask you a followup?
I know that other countries
have normal schools which
are schools meant to train--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah, other
countries have socialist models
and make them work.
But we're just not
as good at that.
AUDIENCE: What prevented
the United States
from developing normal schools
or incorporating normal schools
into their model?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
I don't want to claim
to be an expert on the
creation of normal schools.
But in the 19th
century, the US did
create both the institutions
for mass higher education, i.e.
the public universities,
and high school education
in a very short period of time.
And communities were
essentially realizing
that they had to
upgrade the skills
for an industrial economy
as their population shifted
from farming to working in
manufacturing firms primarily.
And they understood the need
for upgraded skill sets.
And there was an effort
across the country
to create high schools.
Now some regions, particularly
New England, had them.
But the rest of the country,
including the American South,
is pretty quick to
replicate a high school
model as a fix for
a needed skill set.
So that is a massive
social policy
that was done in a remarkably
short period of decades
across the country.
So the country is capable of
making really major changes.
I don't think I
answered your question.
AUDIENCE: That's OK.
I just certainly think it's
important to consider the--
as it was highlighted
I think in several
of the readings, the
role of teachers,
one, moving forward
in the future, two,
how teachers are currently
being educated, three,
teachers are being compensated
and sustained within the model.
They seem to be sort of an
undercurrent of what we're
talking about, but not something
that any of the readings
are willing to address
specifically, and perhaps
strategically for
political reasons.